thank you so much for having me here I'm
really excited to be able to share some
ideas that we've been developing in
terms of designing future memories so
it's a little funny to be doing it here
so close to Silicon Valley because some
of the ideas that we actually have on
technology pretty much fly in the face
of a lot of the common wisdom some of
the amazing things that have come out of
this very area the ideas I'm going to
share with you about memories come from
a long-standing interest in memory in
specifics we've been working on the 9/11
Memorial Museum which we just opened
this last May for eight years we were
partnered with think design to develop
the master plan for the museum and then
designed all the exhibitions and then
designed the media and then produce over
90 different media pieces this is the
slurry wall the so called piece of
infrastructure that withstood the
pressure the Hudson River for a full
year after 9/11 and when President Obama
inaugurated the museum this past May he
said here is where we will tell their
story so that generations yet unborn
will never forget of co-workers who led
others to safety passengers who stormed
a cockpit our men and women in uniform
who rushed into an inferno he was
speaking in specifics about the way in
which we tell stories in the museum
because we made an early decision
actually win the competition to not do
it like a typical museum with a
historian or curator we tell the story
of 9/11 through stories of those who
lived and made history on that day and
it allows us to acknowledge the fact
that 9/11 isn't quite history but it's
not quite current events so when you
first walk into the museum and see this
narrative map made up of people's
memories you're actually aware the fact
that a third of the world watched 9/11
live or heard about it on that day but
you hear the story actually from those
who live through it
it's so fun though in Miami Florida has
got a shot and we were actually in a
meeting when someone barged in and said
oh my god my plane has just crashed into
the World Trade Center once you get to
Aradia and so after you pass through
those different memories of people's
witnessing it from afar and you see them
witnessing it up close you stand in
front of that slurry wall just beyond
they're in witness history yourself and
the museum is a constant dance between
seeing things that are facts things that
are real things that are absolute and
then investigating the memories yourself
so like I mean any memorial it has this
wall of faces and you can see an
individual but here you can actually
select any individual in front of you
and see all of these memories from that
person all of this is donated and
collated from different family members
and you can actually hear in this case a
brother delivering an oral history about
his memory and about who he was and so
mixing between these different memories
you can see these artifacts from the
recovery but also hear from people
inside the towers and what their
experiences are very quiet one of the
firemen from rescue one looked up and he
said we may not live through today and
we looked at him and we looked at each
other and we took the time to shake each
other's hands and wish each other good
luck we're gonna have to walk up 80
flights of stairs with our gear on but
this is what we have to do or going
upstairs and we're going to save
somebody and so we mix together all
these different memories of the past
with acknowledgement that this story is
not over and that it's changing in the
present day and so we have in this final
space which is called foundations fall a
broad array of different experiences but
all of them changing so we have for
example this experience which is an
algorithmic piece it's actually made up
of over 2 million different articles of
the news from September 11th 2001 all
the way to the present day and they
ranged in chronological order according
to different themes that the algorithm
actually puts forward and so this is
constantly changing and updating
acknowledging that 9/11 itself whether
it's the actions in the Middle East or
in Guantanamo are simply not finished
yet and that the event itself is
ever-changing
and then finally the last thing that
visitors do is they're able to leave
their own memories and and actually see
them projected directly onto the slurry
wall itself now this was part of a
general strategy to the museum where we
really wanted people to be able to
synthesize and to come to peace in
whatever way was possible with the
actual museum experience the museum
actually just crossed a million visitors
just since May and over 15 percent of
those visitors write their own mementos
and since most people come in groups
that's pretty much half of the group
members that are coming in that are
writing their own messages and I
literally just I snapped these with my
phone but just to show you what we're
getting my father came home from work
that day in a dusty suit and I thank God
he came home at all or miss you both
everyday love you dad and Chris love
John
or this one we were mere kids when this
happened and now as adults we understand
the impact of this tragic event and it's
actually this one I want to talk about
in particular because I did this event
on 9/11 this year a panel and Bill Hurst
who's an experimental psychologist was
on the panel he studies memory and
specifically he did a study about 9/11
stories and he said oh that's a very
interesting thing that you're doing with
people writing messages afterwards
you're sort of asking about it he said
you know what you're really doing you're
helping them inscribe the memory of the
experience actually deeper inside
themselves I thought this was very
interesting I hadn't quite thought about
it in that way but he basically wanted
to explain that that the brain in this
case the synapses that make up memories
have all these different pathways
hippocampus and amygdala and as you fire
different ones together they actually
literally inscribe the memories deeper
inside of yourself they make a deeper
impression and so I took them out to
lunch a bunch of times and start a
dialogue with them I want to share with
you today some of both our projects from
local projects but also some of the
ideas that he shared with me that make
memories far more impactful so the first
one is we're more confident in our
memories if they involve emotion right
so for this engagement the Cleveland
Museum of Art we were asked by the board
at the end of this huge 350 million
dollar expansion to look at how
technology could engage new visitors
could engage people who didn't know
anything about art or families and
essentially what we did was we looked at
ways at first to delete a lot of the
technology they had planned and then to
make things really simple and
impactful so in this case this woman is
selecting an individual sculpture that's
the original location that that
sculpture is from very simple ways to
basically contextualize these artwork so
that people can make those emotional
connections so that for example this is
the bedroom that that's actually was
painted for totally changes the way you
think about temper paintings or in this
case this is the original castle that
that tapestry was woven for or here is
picasso when he invented cubism right it
suddenly makes this emotional impact or
in this piece which is really probably
the signature part of this engagement
this is all 3,000 artworks that are in
the museum at that time and they're
organized in different ways so loved and
lost color these are different
algorithms that are bringing forward
these artworks but then an individual
visitor can go and select and make
connections between the artworks
themselves right so you can look at them
buy materials you can look them buy
artworks or buy era and then you can
load them onto an iPad to make your own
tour of the museum or lastly and this is
probably one of the craziest ideas our
CD has had this is using facial
detection right so you make a different
face and as the expression is matched it
shows you an artwork that looks like
that so it suddenly transforms the
gallery into place to make that
emotional connection with the artwork
and suddenly it's a social space it's a
space of performance it's a space to
actually make those connections between
people and that's one of the first
sacred cats I'd like to shed is the idea
that social media should actually be
social groups of people in front of
technology itself reminded me of this
mantra which we started using during the
engagement and you can see with
technology this makes a lot of sense
right the idea of participation which is
at the heart of our work this actually
from Ben Franklin like this is just how
humans are we believe and in fact you
see it again in these memories studies
so another study had people taking
photographs inside galleries and sure
enough as you take photographs of
artworks you remember them less that's
just the facts what is interesting
though is if you ask people to take
close-ups to investigate with the
technology they remember twice as much
so this is an engagement for the
cooper-hewitt Smithsonian Design Museum
we're doing this with Diller Scofidio
Renfro we designed this experience and
pitch the museum on a lot of crazy ideas
with the craziest one which is the one
they chose was to allow every single
visitor to have a pen that both tracks
them inside the museum lets them collect
things from the case work but also make
design and in making design you want to
learn more about design itself so it's
exactly putting you in the act of
actually playing designer the pen itself
was developed with partners at GES
Estelle networks makes simply an
undercurrent and it's this wonder of
technology and I'm going to show you
some early prototypes this doesn't open
until December us in our studio we're
constantly building and constructing
these individual pieces so these tables
will be located in select galleries most
of the museum is traditional with
casework but you can draw anywhere and
connect directly with the artifacts
themselves so the collection is open to
you to take with you and to gather and
to make connections one to the next so
you can see all those different
connections between parts of the
collection and save it onto your pen
most importantly as a piece of
inspiration it's not just a scholarship
or an inert artifact sitting in a case
it's there to inspire you as a designer
and of course that's what the
cooper-hewitt so good at but if you just
want to draw this is what happens it
takes any shape that you draw and
matches it directly with a piece in the
collection I mean I've seen this for
hours and hours and I still love to just
watch the ways that these different
formal connections actually play out
because what's amazing is it's making
this formal argument embedded inside of
the technology that all of design starts
with that whether it's digital or
physical a pencil or a pen line work
humans are making things and out of that
comes the entire designed world that we
live within and so when you come up to
any individual digital table you can
just draw a shape and see it matched
directly with a part of the collection
now I'm going to go into wireframes to
show you what happens after that because
again all of this is in process you
actually draw an individual shape and
you get matched with a piece from the
collection but then on the right you see
that those are three different what we
call making apps and it allows you to
essentially digitally create things
inside of the museum to understand more
about the design process and just to
show you what that looks like when you
actually open it up for example this is
an extrude tool and you can see this is
my favorite part on the right it's
matching you with a part of the
collection so this is where we get into
some of the challenges at least in our
mind for software we like software with
an attitude with a point of view in this
case software that tells the story
because it's both giving you a tool but
it's instructing you and showing you the
historic precedents for what you
making and this is just a prototype for
what it's actually gonna look like so
very very very simple tools that allow
you to play with different materials in
different shapes and just again - even
with the simplest of gestures start to
understand something about design itself
or in this case there's different
materials that you can look at this one
is really excellent for making different
stemware
or individual pieces of lamps and then
finally I wanted to share with you this
piece this is really I think the
clincher that the museum really bought
into because we said we want to give
everyone a pen and literally invite them
to draw on the walls it's the opposite
of what anyone would do in a museum but
they have this amazing wallpaper
collection what we said is what we want
visitors to understand wallpaper in a
room that allows you to project 360 on
the room itself so these are just early
style frames in terms of the actual
architecture but the idea is that that
pattern can then be taken with you and
put on your phone or it could even be
printed maybe even downstairs and you
could take it as a product when you
actually leave the museum so this just
show you what the actual room looks like
this is the prototype and this is what
it's like to live draw your own
wallpaper inside of the museum what I
really love about this is that all of
the ways in which people think about
wallpaper like these are the individual
repeat patterns that's actually baked
into the software itself right so it's
teaching you about how software works or
in this case all these lessons from
famous Knoll designers from the 20th
century that's Alexander Girard you use
his palettes you look at different
pieces of inspiration from his work so
it has teaching essentially built into
the interface itself again its software
the serious point of view in a real
attitude it also allows you to actually
move through the historic wallpaper and
to hear oral histories from individuals
talking about that wallpaper and then in
this final shot this is actually the
interface itself as it works and this is
my favorite part see what just happened
there where it said geometric we have
little tool tips from designers who are
just going to talk to you about
different parts of the design process
all right so as you're drawing things
that notices things are doing in this
case Jonathan Adler has a little comment
for you right the idea that you can
actually build expertise into the
software to help you be a better
designer and most of all to inspire you
so I'm just going to show two more
projects
the next one I'm going to show you has
to do with tangibility I mean obviously
a lot of what we're trying to do is to
blend architecture and media together
into experiences and in this case this
idea that people are much more confident
in their mirror in their memories if
they leverage multiple senses this is
for a company called Timken which is an
amazing b2b company that makes precision
mechanics there in Ohio and for example
anyone who flew here probably many
people here there's a 99% chance that
you ended up on their landing gear right
because they make 99% of the mechanics
inside a landing gear here in America
and it's that kind of attitude they make
can't fail mechanics so we tried to
capture that story in partnership with
Davis brand capital that was
reengineering the entire story around
Timken and also for their new global
headquarters which really focuses on
innovation and on mixing together design
and expertise what they know and what
they make the actual precision
fabrication itself so I'm just going to
focus on two interfaces all of them
embed stories and parts of context
within it but in our case what we talked
them into was using tour guides with
using people the human face of Timken
and really they're only doing very very
high-end engineer towards right I think
that's essentially their customer base
so in this case they're trying to show
the context the world's largest wind
farm this is the longest tunnel ever
drilled in the world right they only do
these very very extreme forms of
engineering or this the Mars rover
they're inside of each of the three
Rovers making its way and you can see
Mars rover Curiosity bearing its a
quarter inch precision radial bearing it
operates at 100,000
it's extremely efficient and I love that
moment of pride right the ability to
hold up a single piece of mechanics and
understand exactly what it was that it
was doing there on Mars and so what we
did was we said well we want your
customers to be able to actually touch
and unfold and take these precision
mechanics apart and the engineers were
coiled they were like first of all these
things are way way too important and
precise to actually be touched even the
chrome itself we don't even let the
salespeople touch any of these pieces
but what we did do is we make a virtual
version where people can actually
understand what's inside these bearings
on a very very precise engineering level
so again this is all alt or LED so I
think that makes a specific bond itself
where you can answer any questions but
the ability to then magically dissolve
and open up to actually show all the
engineering inside of all these
individual precision pieces really is
what's able to communicate both the
larger context of impact and then on a
very very specific level all the little
engineering details that really prove
exactly what Timken is bringing forward
and then of course the customers can
play with it themselves and that's a
huge part I think of what they're
offering the ability to actually see and
manipulate to make that deeper contact
with things that are literally invisible
is a huge part of this engagement so the
last thing that I'm going to share with
you which I think actually wraps a lot
of these ideas all together is this
piece that we're building for the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation along with
the US Federal Department of Education
so it's sort of a funny double funding
source right you have the most sort of
extreme innovators and then a highly
conservative organizations coming
together along with the New York Hall of
Science and a number of other funders to
come up with a learning system around
middle school physics and we had this
idea early on in the engagement we
thought you know there's probably the
scenario where you have these sort of
bored kids sitting in class and they're
just seeing these formulas and hearing a
teacher maybe drone on they can't quite
understand what is being talked about in
terms of Newtonian physics and all these
abstractions right about gravity about
inertia about momentum and rotation and
then they would leave that classroom and
run out onto the playground and on a
swing or on a slide literally embody all
of those exact same ideas if you think
about it
playgrounds are essentially Newtonian
physics machines first extract those
forces on our own body and so what we
did was we built out a system that
actually allows kids to play on the
playground in in playing actually learn
about physics essentially to do physics
experiments on their own body so this is
an early prototype that we shot and
again if you think about dodgeball right
dodgeball is everything that you need to
know in terms of Newtonian physics so
you have momentum you have inertia you
have a mass she's gonna throw this ball
this is Larry's lookout vericose right
but the ability to then have this
experience as a kid and then to turn
around and to start to extract patterns
not even knowledge but patterns out of
it is a huge aspect so what they do is
they trace the individual video and then
the patterns start to arise now as a
technologist we were really excited
because we knew the power of this
platform is to basically do all of the
math to reveal all of the physics inside
of it but the educators stopped us
immediately they said no no and this
actually the memory memory scientists
underscore he said if you tell someone
the answer to a math problem there is
zero chance they will ever remember it
period
there's just nothing there there's no
friction and what we started discovering
is in learning applications you actually
want to build friction and we call it
positive friction so again this is the
opposite of what I think a lot of
software is doing today you need
friction in order for people to actually
retain it so we actually bury a lot of
the information inside of the app so you
basically have to move through it to
discover even some simple mathematics in
terms of distance or rates or if you
click in further you can get into a
force diagram and start to put the
pieces together and you might even have
parts of the application that look like
this that have some learning actually
built into it that have something that's
closer to a sort of knowledge base but
this is actually quite controversial in
education do you even offer this level
of application in terms of the
prototyping it's a complete joy because
you're out on the playground with kids
playing and that's the whole idea all
they're doing is playing and discovering
and playing and discovering and that
process of allowing kids to go out there
and in the midst of a play activity be
curious and to actually undiscovered and
reveal all the ways in which our daily
activities the things that we already
know
to be true are actually embedded inside
the physics itself that is really where
the joy comes in and so in this footage
we shot this just a week ago makers for
actually you can see it's constantly
asking again this social experience
where someone's telling someone
something else to do and then they're
using the application itself together to
actually reveal a lot of these patterns
and to understand and if as you can see
that's actually a live graph of the
actual physics itself built into the
video so everything Laird from their
experience comes out and builds it out
now we really want to endorse Scott's
idea about this idea of a new era I mean
I think this is really a new era in
terms of the future of learning for us
we take it really as this great leap
forward about how people are going to be
learning and the types of future
memories that we're going to be able to
build with them and so for us this idea
of something that's tactile something
that's multi-sensory something that has
productive friction that's social that
builds in a human relationship in
congruity with technology that's
emotional at its core that's what the
future of learning is and I think
honestly with those types of tenants we
can start to build things that will last
far far into the future all the way
until it becomes part of the past thank
you so much